federal health officials are appealing
to pregnant women to get vaccinated
against covit and they're trying to make
the case the benefits of the vaccine
outweigh the known or potential risks
there have been more than 125 000 cases
of covet in pregnant women in the united
states resulting in more than 22
thousand hospitalizations and 161 deaths
as maria villareal reports the
resistance to get vaccinated has brought
heartache to some expecting families
austin carrington never pictured a
future where he'd be raising his 15
month old son hollis
alone it's not easy for you is it
no
i miss her so much
austin and bianca carrington had plans
for a big family they recently found out
they were pregnant with their second
child when bianca who was unvaccinated
was diagnosed with covet 19. looking
back on it
i thought we were playing it safe by not
getting the vaccine
because of the baby and now turns out
getting the vaccine would have been the
safe bet
while sick with covet the 29 year old
miscarried she was later intubated and
died august 24th
her death is just one of the many
heartbreaking cases involving expectant
mothers
last month the cdc received 20 reports
of pregnant women who died of covid
across the country nearly a thousand
covet cases involving a pregnant woman
were reported each week during july and
august
still only about 30 percent of pregnant
women are fully vaccinated is there any
doubt in your mind
that those deaths could have been
prevented if these mothers had been
vaccinated oh there's there's no doubt
in my mind we we didn't have to lose the
mothers we lost
dr rachel morris is a high risk ob gyn
at the university of mississippi medical
center in nearly four weeks her hospital
lost five pregnant women
all of them unvaccinated i have never
in my career
been
this afraid for the patients i care for
it's my job it's my calling
but it's not supposed to be this way
okay here we are day 59
since my wife contracted coveted 19 and
gave birth at 38 weeks jamal chubb has
been documenting on social media his
wife sierra's battle with kovid back in
july she was pregnant with their third
child when she contracted the virus
sierra did not get the vaccination
because at the time we did not have the
cdc come out and say they recommended it
for pregnant women and it wasn't fda
approved yet the cdc recommended
pregnant women get the vaccine in august
after sierra was already hospitalized i
do wish we had the information we have
now
wish we had that sooner sierra is still
in the hospital on a ventilator but
she's improving and jamal is hopeful
she'll be able to come home soon
maybe miles is also doing well
we shared austin carrington's story with
jamal
he's living every um
significant other's worst nightmare
right now whoa
look i don't want any other
women to
uh
to pass away because of it i couldn't
think of anyone worse to lose for cbs
mornings medea villarreal arlington
texas
it is one thing to miscarry that's tough
enough but to lose your life
your wife
i can't imagine it i know a lot of imams
to be agonized over this at the
beginning because they didn't know
whether the vaccination was right but
now the evidence seems pretty clear and
it's the right thing to do and if that
doesn't get the message through i don't
know what will for some of these women
and these families out there
maria wonderful report